2014 was a big year for me do you ever
have that just like a big year like a
banner year
for me it went like this october 3rd i
lost my second pregnancy
and then october 8th my dad died of
cancer
and then on november 25th my husband
aaron died after three years with stage
four glioblastoma which is just a fancy
word for brain cancer
so i'm fun
now since 2014 i will tell you i have
remarried
a very handsome man named matthew we
have four children
in our blended family we live in the
suburbs of minneapolis
minnesota usa we have a rescue dog
i drive a minivan like the kind where
doors open i don't even touch them
by any measure life is really really
good but i haven't moved on
i haven't moved on and i hate that
phrase so much and i understand why
other people do because what it says
is that aaron's life and death and love
are just
moments that i can leave behind me
and that i probably should and when i
talk about aaron i slip
so easily into the present tense and
i've always thought that made me weird
and then i noticed that everybody does
it
and it's not because we are in denial or
because we're forgetful it's because the
people we love who we've lost are still
so
present for us so
when i say oh aaron is
it's because aaron still is he's present
for me in the work that i do and the
child that we had together
and these three other children i'm
raising who never met him who shared
none of his dna but who are only in my
life
because i had aaron and because i lost
aaron he's present
in my marriage to matthew because
aaron's life
and love and death made me the person
that matthew wanted to marry so i've not
moved on from aaron i've moved forward
with him these are the experiences that
mark us
and make us just as much as the joyful
ones
and justice permanently
long after you get your last sympathy
card or your last hot dish
like we don't look at the people around
us experiencing life's joys and wonders
and tell them to move on do we
we don't like send a card that's like
congratulations on your beautiful baby
and then
five years later think like another
birthday party get over it
but grief is kind of one of those things
like falling in love or having a baby or
watching the wire on hbo where
you don't get it until you get it until
you do it
and once you do it once it's your love
or your baby once it's your grief
and your front row at the funeral
you get it you understand what you're
experiencing is not a
moment in time it's not a bone that will
reset but that you've been touched by
something chronic
something incurable it's not fatal but
sometimes grief feels like it could be
and if we can't prevent it in one
another
what can we do we need each other
to remember to help each other remember
that grief is this multitasking
emotion that you can and will be sad and
happy
you'll be grieving and able to love in
the same year or week
the same breath we need to remember that
a grieving person
is going to laugh again and smile again
if they're lucky they'll even find love
again
that yes absolutely they're going to
move forward
but that doesn't mean that they've moved
on